welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you
too much information about the sex life
of comic book characters
or um i guess to keep that cca approval
of the lack thereof
because i'm sure s cap told dude
somebody you had to watch at school kids
it is great to wait and you wonder why
you waited so long for something so
disappointing
oh peter peter you're taking that the
wrong way no no no
oh there goes that stamp of approval
dang it oh wow been there been there
don't tell us
damn it we almost had it back whoops
whoops at daisies
i'm eric boss here with me to check
these super hero v
cards like some bouncer at a sex night
club tommy beck told who actually
once worked alongside me as a bouncer at
a hollywood
sex nightclub that we like to call ios
oh
yes every layer of that beloved curse in
space
oozing with the essence of uh comedy and
romance
and also which just smells like
desperation and body sweat which meant
sweat and uh
the the couches of people's parents that
lived in the greater los angeles area
who donated those couches
also remember when we were bouncers we
had to give people a permanent stamp on
their wrist
people loved them you know where if you
were wearing a white shirt and it was in
the ac was broken as it often was
yeah don't cross your arms because
you're going to ruin that shirt
well great to be here eric uh as usual
much like the heroes
that we're gonna talk about today my sex
life is confusing
at times uneventful and at other times
so eventful
that it requires multiple spin-off books
uh anyway
sex can be a very awkward and
uncomfortable subject
um especially the longer you wait but
you know what that's totally okay
we put too much of it on pedestals all
kinds of things on pedestals yeah so our
question
that tommy's going to tackle today a
tommy tackle yes
although we have explored the question
of which superheroes can
or can't bang based on you know their
anatomy or their powers
but one thing we have not explored which
superheroes
are virgins and you know virgins by
choice or
by um lack of uh opportunity i guess
looking at you
donatello of the ninja turtles eric as
as
is uh uh appropriate with any uh
discussion of sex
there's no pressure here we're not
pressuring anybody everyone here is free
to move at their own pace but let's
start with our virgins by anatomy the
the people who
remain pure through no fault of their
own god just didn't give them the parts
to get down with or took away their
parts to get down with that's true or
god cursed them either way these are
people that ain't getting it on as they
say
oh let's start with groot we're talking
about full-grown adult group for those
of you that are about to get you know
all fired up about this we're talking
about adult group from guardians one
he reproduces asexually so in a way
group [ __ ] all the time groot is
constantly having sex with himself i'm
doing it
right now which is a lot like how things
were for me from age 15 to 18
to 19. actually 15 to 37 to be honest
with you
just keep rounding up that's a year in
the future but i'm going to assume
things aren't going to get any better
you need me i'll be in holodeck 4. next
we have
ben grimm aka the thing who has no
genitalia in rock form
what is [ __ ] end of the stick that he
got a few days in space
it'll be great what's the worst that
could happen uh you're gonna turn into a
giant rock with no penis
perfect however ben grimm was a college
football star
and if i know anything about playing
college football which i do because i
did
some people get laid on the team
presumably i sure didn't so
he might have got it on if he was a
quarterback it stands to reason that he
would very sexy yeah college age michael
chiklis he's picking up all the chick
and he's never chick less yeah oh he's
chick moore
he's tons of chicks then we have rogue
unfortunate rogue
who is so powerful that if she touches
someone uh they will
uh die so in some comics she has
dampened her powers in order to
have intercourse so good for her for
making herself small as all women are
taught to do just kidding delete that
john don't record that
uh she dampens her powers uh
and so yeah but is it the real thing if
she's not going 100
i need full sense from rogue you know
next go to our next category
death not virgins definitely not virgins
these are people we have
talked about in previous episodes we
have the hulk planet hulk grey hulk
this dude gets down all the time
presumably he has to do a lot of
redecorating because i can't imagine
intercourse with him
resolves in a lot of beds staying intact
i would assume he's a bed breaker
you know there's nothing wrong with that
or who has time for her beds when you're
hulk
that's right hulk smash hulk build ikea
furniture after breaking bad
sorry janet uh and then there's superman
who has sex with lois lane and has kids
with
her in story lines and movies starring
kevin spacey that we can't talk about
then there's wonder woman and let's face
it diana is
boldly sexually liberated and that's a
good thing so let's talk about the ones
who
are the the what we understand a virgin
to be
it's like it's not necessarily about
their anatomy right right what is it
really about
it's a question of uh their character's
identity their priorities their
timidness
politeness emotional barriers a lot of
it's all in your head you know i mean i
can remember
as you said uh so eloquently earlier the
longer you wait the more stressful it
gets because there's all these
expectations that you're supposed to do
it and it's going to be this incredible
thing
or it's going to be this terrible thing
all the more reason to do it even faster
but what does that do
it breeds fear and we can't uh
we can't put up emotional barriers eric
we have to we have to go into this
with it with a sense of excitement and
wonder and and understand that
everyone's human or superhuman or
metahuman
and hey and we should say for some
people it's not a point of anxiety it's
a point of pride some people are as they
say
involuntary celibate which we definitely
have some in cells on our list we're
gonna get too right
that's right and in our comments uh so
we'll get to them as well so oh no so
let's start off with spiderman aka peter
parker
in the mcu peter parker is probably a
virgin because he's 17 and he's super
nerdy it's doubtful
that m mj went that far in the final
minutes of far from home
although sure what a great place europe
were they in i believe uh europe is a
great place to lose your virginity yeah
they had one final night in the ruins of
london they could uh
maybe i went to europe as a young man
and i'll be honest with you i kept my
virginity and i kept it
with full authority based on uh his
reaction to the uh blonde agent who told
him to take off his clothes
he's probably very unfamiliar with that
sort of intimacy so
stances in the mcu our peter parker is a
virgin however in the comics
no no no no no my friend peter parker
is getting it on with mary jane all the
time he
is getting nasty he is staying classy
he's getting
bougie he's getting ratchet and episode
in issue 50
aunt may actually walks in on them does
not join because it's not a pornhub
weird
simulated scenario but she does walk in
so then we have peter getting married mj
later in the comics and let's presume
that they
have a healthy marriage and have sex and
then in one timeline they actually have
a daughter
and i don't know if i was lied to in
biology class but a child usually
requires intercourse if you're watching
this video your parents have elected for
you not to be present in the health
class for a discussion of
human reproduction and another issue
peter parker's radioactive semen
actually gives mj cancer which is you
know
definitely an abstinence tool you could
be at risk for a number of sexually
transmitted diseases
something to persuade people yeah that
feels like abstinence propaganda like
do not have sex because the semen is
radioactive and we'll give you cancer
that's no pimple michael
you mean cancer that's like seventh
grade health class chlamydia
gonorrhea herpes cancer from radioactive
semen
all on the table if you're gonna risk it
guys the only way to
truly prevent any of those is abstinence
or
vibranium let's move on to our next
our next potential virgin this this is
so creepy our next potential version
yes what are we doing to them
let's move on to our next subject
captain america steve rogers
very wholesome very very awes very
all-american
in the mcu possibly he may be a virgin
he could have had sex on the uso tour
or during his time in world war ii
france with peggy or private lorraine
hello
but he's pretty much a boy scout and in
an avengers deleted scene he flirts with
a waitress
which is like you know his game is
pretty weak plus we've got free wireless
radio and end game writers talked about
a scene idea showing steve
living with sharon carter but that
didn't happen because again
this isn't a pornhub incest scenario so
like he can't just date all generations
we don't know if it's incest i guess
it's just
depends how you interpret hey if it's
possible to interpret it as incest
it's incest that's what i say you always
have to assume the worst in people
anyway back to the virgins
presumably he banged peggy carter when
he went back in time
but we never see it happen and you know
the rules are the same for him
as it were for me when my friends
bullied me when i was a junior in high
school
if you haven't seen it it didn't happen
so our friend steve rogers is most
definitely
a virgin in the end yeah hey he could
have talked about in that final scene
sam was asking him for
for the details yes and he goes no i
don't think i will
so until you do spill that tea cap
you're a verge also
sam chill out maybe just let the guy
have his own personal life
sam's like first thought was like how
much sex did you have while you went
back in time
tell me everything you must have had sex
what 15
16 times all right in the comics sorry
my friends
kept staying getting nasty okay
a lot he sleeps with peggy carter at one
point he sleeps with scarlet
witch and let me tell you that's a range
you know that's showing an eclectic
taste in sexual partners
so one can literally make your
nightmares come true and the other one
is scarlet witch
hey and this goes to show you kids this
is why it's so important to read the
comics because in the movies they have
to stay pg pg-13
you know right they don't go into it but
in the comics everyone is [ __ ]
everyone
and everyone's so much cooler in the
comics so that's why you gotta read
these things
and that's why i escaped to them
it's real though that's where everyone's
cool
coming to the pages of my haunted comic
eric
all right moving on uh this is no
this one's a bit of a wild card uh a bit
of a joker if you will
it is the joker in the movies and the
movers in the movies
heath ledger and joaquin phoenix could
be virgins we don't know
jared leto joker just likes to watch
he's definitely got subscriptions to
multiple porn sites
talking deredorm talking college rules
talking
my first sex teacher talking naughty
america
talking browsers and any other sites uh
go ahead
and uh drop them in the comments below
with your passwords and login no do not
oh sorry don't don't do that don't
comment below cut that out
uh however in other media it is hinted
that joker and harley quinn
are having sex i've recently watched an
episode of the harley quinn show on hbo
max and
yeah it's pretty strongly implied that
they have a sexual relationship in the
arkham city game
there was a pregnancy test in his
hideout by harley's thing
so you know yeah i mean it's the joker
though is the problem
who knows what his sick mind is doing in
injustice year one
harley admits to black canary that she
and the joker had a kid that she hid
from him the mad love episode of batman
the animated series
harley buys lingerie to seduce the joker
and it's implied in batman the animated
series so
that's you know strong evidence that
they uh are intimate
and in another comic she and avi are
talking about sex and harley mentions
that she and joker do it but he's
mean so if he's not a virgin he's not uh
the type of non-virgin i want to be
involved with
exactly yeah and you know also in the
killing joke there's the whole stuff
that he did with the the gordon family
it depends on which joker you're talking
about i i like to think our most recent
live-action joker uh arthur fleck is
absolutely
a virgin that guy's uh a textbook and so
and not exactly a guy you're rooting for
to lose his virginity let's be honest
but someone i'm always rooting for in
every aspect of life is galactus
galactus reproduces asexually ever since
merging with the sentient embodiment of
the universe after the big bang
as you do who has time to have sex when
you've merged
with the sentient embodiment of the big
bang theory
five billion years later which is a long
time to wait eat your heart out steve
carell
he is still a virgin but before that
when he was just a humanoid explorer of
todd named gallon
he might have had sex i mean stands to
reason but then he evolved to this other
state
of being where he's basically a god and
he's like
i don't see anyone as my equal i don't
want to
because you know to copulate requires a
bit of vulnerability
and uh i don't think galactus wants to
signal that kind of vulnerability
i mean that's kind of like adrian vite
right like adrian viton washington is
like i can't like no one is worthy of my
seed
that type of that's right yeah and
that's how i feel and that's a lot of
the reason why i'm not more sexually
active eric is i just don't find anyone
worthy
no one is no one's good enough for my
tommy someone's gonna take that
literally and write i don't like that
guy
uh okay so next we have king shark and
boy oh boy
would i could i marry kill all three
king shark in a 2013 comic
suicide squad number 13 to be exact
another character states king shark
is most likely a virgin but in batman
arkham knight the prequel comic that is
we meet his son kid shark oh i'll go kid
shark now
sharks have been known to have virgin
births but not male sharks so
that would be quite an incredible yeah
uh okay and also in the dc animated
harley quinn show
he gets married plus agrees with his
wife to have relationships on the site
so he's in an open
relationship uh so sick more
right there's also a whole thing at
justice league dark apocalypse war that
seemed to suggest
a sexual relationship between king shark
and
john constantine so whoa
that's kind of wild and i like to
imagine it as keanu john constantine
oh yeah we all do and ron funch is king
shark that's the least the noises the
the voices i hear so i guess when it
comes to king shark
it just depends on which version you're
talking about or which
virgin you're talking about i'll be here
all night
which virgin version i'll be here all
lonely night
all right next war shock rorschach is
almost certainly a virgin and not
because of the side effects from his
superpowers
but just having a lot of mental hang-ups
you know a lot of things to understand
his mother was a prostitute and he has a
lot of psychosexual complexes
in the before watchmen comic he did ask
out a nice waitress but while waiting
for him to show up
she got tortured by a bad guy so that
experience was probably enough for him
to swear off dating or sex for a while
so a lot of trauma there it's not really
seems to be rorschach's fault
interesting you have rorschach and you
have ozymandias
and until they had that alleluia scored
sex scene
daniel dryberg as well yeah so that's
interesting a lot of virgins in the
watchmen universe but that's pretty
accurate
right and there's just something about
the music of leonard cohen that makes
you want to
shed all your clothes and roll around in
your house
all right next we have oh man
again if he's not tell give him my cell
number
thanos whoa in the comics thanos is a
lothario
you know he is that thick eggplant of a
man his whole mo is trying to woo
lady death by killing half the universe
and who hasn't tried that
who hasn't gone to the extremes to
impress a woman okay i once painted a
car with spray paint you can't do that
you shouldn't do that but i did to try
and impress a girl
she wasn't impressed she started going
out with my friend it didn't work
half a universe painting a car with
spray paint equal actions me and
thanos are basically the same person as
what i'm saying yeah later in the comics
he had a son feign oh god that's his
name
uh after having sex with an inhuman
woman so
not a lowercase inhuman woman like you
know an inhuman
you don't have the word in front of them
inhuman yes inhuman woman uh okay in the
mcu
there is no sexual activity suggested
his focus is
not solely on calling various
civilizations and getting those stones
as an eco-terrorist thanos would be phil
probably be philosophically opposed to
procreating and increasing the
population
yeah even by one so in the mcu i have no
choice but to against all
odds say thanos is a virgin wow
i think you are right wow that's
interesting in fact many of these
villains are because if you're a super
villain it means you have had to have
commit your life
to doing evil things and being
emotionally disconnected from people so
when are you gonna have time
what do you have time to have a healthy
sexual relationship i mean loki probably
has
but uh not ultron right it's like i mean
like listen
this day and age dating is like an
escape room you've gotta answer a series
of questions so correct
just to get out of there who could fault
steppenwolf
from that justice league movie for being
a virgin he's got so much going on
i don't blame him who's got the time
right keyboard warriors
call in if you agree so there you have
it kiddos you don't need to uh worry too
much
yes if you read the comics pretty much
everyone is but
in the world of the movies no one is
especially if you're a super villain um
actually i think we're learning the
wrong lesson here
because we have seen some real world in
cells become super villains
don't want that to be the path forward
for them yes just know
that you can be a voluntary celibate
just don't do evil things
in your spare time that you now have
looking at you bar stool sports as an
entire company
anyway uh i would also say that this is
like
very much like the real world both
mediums imply
a lot of sexual activity and the reality
is probably somewhere far less so
if you are watching this in high school
and this is making you more stressed out
don't worry about it most of us are
lying and just trying to survive and get
through the day without feeling like a
total [ __ ] so
you know take this all worth a great
exactly remember that
each one of these sexual conquests by
both men and women
with whatever partners was written by a
sweaty man leaning over a piece of paper
in his new jersey apartment for pennies
on the dollar of what he was worth
so and i say man and i realize even that
is sexist so man or woman
in their sweaty new jersey apartment for
way less historically
historically they were dudes all right
anyway let's pay some bills
let us move on to some people helped us
make this episode starting with our
friends at draftkings
the teams are back out on the gridiron
for the nfl season
there's no better place to get in on all
the action than with draftkings
the leader in one day fantasy sports to
add to this week's excitement draftking
says millions of dollars in total prizes
up for grabs
you haven't tried draftkings yet head to
the app store right now because
you do not want to miss this draft your
lineup now and feel
the sweat like never before every run
every pass every catch means more with
draft games
i'm doing a performance art for you an
interpretive dance
yes very interpretive like many of the
plays conducted by the buffalo bills
yes it is oh no
no no no oh god they are smashing
through my folding tables downstairs i
have to finish up i get through this
look i'm a jacksonville jaguars boy um
but my second team
of my heart my side piece would be the
buffalo bill yes
he's in bill's mafia you heard it here
first the slow gradual takeover of new
rock stars is upon us
off-screen producer zach in the mafia
pretty ricky eric boss
in the mafia who's next marina mastros a
boy can dream
a boy can dream but getting back to
draftkings
it's super simple all you gotta do pick
your lineup stay under the salary cap
and see how your team stacks up against
the competition
nothing adds to the excitement of
watching the game quite like having a
shot at millions of dollars in prizes
am i right that's right draftkings has
paid out billions of dollars to winners
since 2012
so they know a thing or two about
cooldown cash
just download the draftkings app right
now and use the code big question and
for a limited time new users
can get a free shot at millions of
dollars in prizes this week
and don't miss out on the week 2 action
enter code big
question to get a free shot of millions
of dollars in prizes
with your first deposit that's code big
question only at draftkings
make it rain minimum 5 deposit required
eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for more details
oh baby i can't wait to bet on those
buffalo bills and i can't wait to hit my
parents up for money when i lose all my
money
betting on those buffalo bills it's
football season uh we also want to thank
our friends at upstart so during these
economically turbulent times
everyone is looking for a way to feel
more financially secure right so if
you're still needlessly throwing money
every month at high interest credit card
debt
it's time you checked out upstart the
revolutionary online lending platform
that knows you are more than just a
credit score
now is the time to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
to help pay off high interest credit
card debt unlike other lenders upstart
can reward you based on your education
your job history
in the form of a smarter rate you don't
need a degree or a diploma to apply
though
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely
online they offer loans from 1 000 to 50
000 so you can consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment
upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate since it's just a soft
pull
it won't affect your credit score when
you check it the hard pull happens if
you accept a rate and proceed with your
application the best part if the loan is
approved and accepted most people get
their funds the very next business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt and get back
to using your money
your way with upstart see why upstart
has a 4.9 out of five rating on
trespilot and hurry to upstart.com
bigquestion to find out how low your
upstart rate can be checking your rate
only takes a few minutes that's
upstart.com
bigquestion your loan amount will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application not all
applicants will qualify for the full
amount
all right well eric uh i have to say
that
i am intrigued by the soft poll but even
more excited by the hard polls so i will
be checking in to upstart
how about now we get to a few bite-sized
questions do you feel good about that
can i hit you with a future i feel real
good i want to take a couple
nibbles yeah let's do a few nibbles dr
zoidberg huge fan of yours dr zoidberg
on discord
asks who is the richest character in the
marvel universe and
uh also who is the richest in the dc
universe or just keep throwing universes
at us zoidberg
you want to stand sir who's also the
richest milwaukee dead universe in the
james bond universe
all this man cares about as well is dr
zoidberg scrooge mcduck
i think he is thank you for limited
adjusted marvel and dc
according to a bunch of different
estimates we could find online in the
marvel world
uh tony stark you would think is the
richest his estimated net worth is 100
billion dollars which would make him the
richest person i think in our world
where where is bezos at right now
i think he's over 100 billion i thought
he just i thought he's like 130 or
something
that is depressing even our fictional
billionaires can't even come ah
no it's good it's great it's awesome
draftkings upstart
however in the marvel world t'challa
as the absolute monarch of wakanda his
wealth is tied directly to his country's
gdp and wealth reserves
which includes that big ass mound of
vibranium
which in the marvel world is more
valuable than gold 10 000
per gram so it's estimated that he could
be worth
90 trillion with a t trillion dollars
an ungodly amount of money but that's
only because someone decided to make
vibranium worth
ten thousand dollars per gram which
would be a completely
insane wealth imbalance and and man
every time we mentioned t'challa
god this is it's just like so it's so
sad
it's awful god we miss that guy so much
though technically some people say
thor is the richest character in the
marvel universe because
as the owner of all the treasures in the
odin vault or
asgard vault yes it's countless but we
don't really have any way to numerically
quantify it so we're going to put black
panther at the top
meanwhile over in dc lex luthor is worth
75 billion dollars bruce wayne is just a
bit richer than him worth
80 billion dollars but the richest is
aquaman worth 150
trillion dollars where does that never
come from well at one point
he does estimate that he has 60 billion
in shipwrecked treasure
but people have done estimates based on
the amount of gold that is estimated to
be
on the ocean floor around the world and
that aquaman rules something like
three quarters of the ocean right uh so
they're able to get their way up to
using extrapolation 150 trillion dollars
well plus he
only wears fisherman's sweaters with
holes in them or no [ __ ]
so he doesn't spend a lot of money on
fashion that's what it is it's about how
much you spend on how much you save
okay arthur you rich [ __ ] uh moving on
below k but rk on discord asks
superman's heat vision versus cyclops is
optic blast
who does more damage all right in both
cases
neither has been definitively quantified
i would say both
the superman heat vision and the optic
blast from cyclops are capable of doing
insane
amounts of damage based on whatever
situation they're in but we can
measure it based on the source of their
power so superman derives of course this
energy from
solar energy from our sun so superman
seat vision is a direct function
of whatever the energy he's getting from
our sun in our solar system
scott summers optic blast and we have
talked about this a big question before
it is insane if you did not know this
they come from portals in his eyes that
open to an
alternate dimension a dimension that is
filled with
infinite levels of kinetic energy so
based on that
our known universe is sun versus an
infinite other dimension
i would have to say cyclops's optic
blasts have the potential to be far more
destructive and limitless in his
universe but neither of these two will
ever be in the same universe hopefully
all right cute portals uh cyclops i like
that
he's such dreamy portals that's how i
felt for him it was his portals first
yeah all right
bring us on home with glenn on discord
asking
what irl short for in real life or i'm
really loud
uh what irl attempts have there been to
make something like
compound v or super soldier serum okay
well
it doesn't exist these things do not
exist in the real world and it's pretty
much
impossible to do things like this
because super powers are
impossible but the closest we get there
are
not
the nazis did a available of human
experimentation on concentration camp
victims a lot of human testing's really
messed up stuff they did four steroids
on some workers to keep them working
despite starving them
but you know we're looking at steroids
steroids have used been used for all
kinds of stuff the russians used it to
help advance their athletes
a lot of american athletes have done it
on their own too and of course there are
various medical uses for steroids any
time you get surgery often you're given
uh some kind of steroid to help like
regrow certain muscle tissue
because that's what steroids are they
don't make you stronger it's not like
bane juice they just help widen your
body's capacity to regrow muscle tissue
as you need to regrow it from like
typical means like working out like
lifting that's what steroids
are i think most people would say that
is not at all the same thing as compound
v
or super soldier serum but super soldier
serum part of that
cocktail was a steroid that's what
erskine said it was to promote
muscle growth but then he had some other
kind of mystery ingredient
that uh that we'll never know some
people have also compared it to the uh
crispr
genetic editing technique in which you
know we can kind of edit
genes before birth including
theoretically the
subject to gain more muscle mass like
you have seen those dogs that are
genetically bred to be like jacked dogs
yes but that's not the same thing either
right no it's not like a drug you can
take and if we're whiting out further
yeah there have been a lot of advances
in prosthetics artificial limbs
artificial organs
now they're doing some amazing stuff
with uh prosthetic audio nerves optic
nerves so
people who have like hearing issues are
able to hear for the first time in those
videos that make us all cry when we
watch them
and i guess you can compare that to the
winter soldier arm
but like really if you look into all
those they're all there to try to
get you close to what you had before
they all have limitations they don't
really
give you superpowers right it's just
artificial replacements of
of you know what the natural form would
be so yes compound b doesn't exist but
yeah there are all kinds of attempts to
modify the human body and and improve it
in ways or fix it in certain ways
but i don't think any of that is science
fictiony all right we have
uh time for one more box of scraps
question
all right and staying on theme this week
tommy we've been talking a lot a game
about virginity but let's rewind the
clock and try to empathize with some
other people
what uh would you say was a time that
you felt the most
insecure about your virginity when you
were younger oh
geez well it was so long ago
so let me try and even remember back
then but uh
yeah you know i think i was raised
catholic as i believe you were
eric so yeah i was very secure about
being a virgin for a long time like i
did not
not only did i think that it was fine
i thought it was like a badge of honor
well into my teens like that was like
i'm not having sex time getting married
are you kidding me what's like
right yeah do you understand how wrong
that is and then
yeah i got you know into my first kind
of like i guess
young adult relationship when i was like
15 and like
i remember the girl that i was dating at
the time was also very religious and
like
we were both under so much pressure
because we were in a relationship
we dated for like three years in high
school and people were just like
you have to have sex with each other and
we were both kind of like
slowly coming out of our being religious
i guess for lack of a better word or
like or at least feeling uh
obligation to our religion i wouldn't
say i was never like a like super
catholic but like
we both were kind of like we'll just
continue to tell people we're having sex
but we won't
actually be having sex because we're way
too nervous so i would say
like my junior year of high school when
the last year i was with my girlfriend
we were at the time
we were just putting out into the
universe that we had this like crazy
teen
sex life like that edit that that's
disgusting cut that out but
like we were but we were like you know
like teens on an mtv show or like
riverdale but in reality we were uh
watching a lot
of game show network
hey you know what that's a much better
way when you're that age to spend your
time game show network's great
i i feel like i i can't i you know just
to put a fine point on the
on the whole thing i one thing i have no
regrets about
being a kid was that i allowed myself to
be a kid for a long time you know like i
did
i wasn't in a huge hurry to grow up as
like a 13 or 14 year old i was pretty
naive i didn't really watch
super hard rated movies until i was like
16 or 17.
and thus was like kind of had a blissful
ignorance for a long time
now it made it harder to catch up when i
was older but like
you know i don't i kind of appreciate
that when i was like a 13 and 14 year
old i wasn't a
horny maniac so uh
well tommy it sounds like you had that
kind of easy a life you know
or where people pretend where i think
that's like the more scandalous way most
kids in high school
if anyone if you're in high school and
kids are talking about having sex yeah
they're probably not there's like a at
least 70
chance they're lying absolutely
absolutely and i think it was the thing
it was
the nice thing was i had a partner in
crime on it so it was like
i wasn't claiming i had sex with a girl
who didn't even know who i was
it was like we were both just trying to
you know take the pressure off of
ourselves but
tommy i i had a very similar thing grew
up catholic
uh similar kind of teenage years i
didn't have an opportunity i didn't have
i had one girlfriend at the end of uh
but we only dated for a couple
months and it never really got that
serious uh then in high school
i dated more in my 20s in high school i
was not cool
um i am still not cool i was cool we're
cutting all this
we're very cool look at us now look what
we do i have a baby
on my coffee maker you've got a blue
dungeon
we're talking about people comic book
characters having sex for a living
hey that's pretty cool if i told teenage
me that would be my life
my god i'd be like what are you doing
what are you did you enhance
it easier the playboy mansion what is
your life uh anyway
um but yeah um my parents um
we didn't really talk about a whole lot
but i remember the summer when i was 17
years old
uh my dad and i uh were talking about
how like um
this other girl who i had gone to middle
school with and went to the catholic
high school
because you know it's a big thing with
like catholic kids of catholic high
school because they only teach them
abstinence yeah they never
learn safe sex so they get pregnant
they totally get pregnant and this girl
was like the valedictorian of her school
and there's nothing wrong with getting
pregnant but like
you know it just sucks when you're in
this it forces your life in one
direction that they was an unplanned
pregnancy and
my dad was so freaked out by it so he
and i were sitting outside he's just
like hey eric um
if you're ever in that situation just
promise me
promise me that you use protection i'm
like but father
yes i i don't understand i'm not
going to be doing that until i am uh
happily wed
the safety of marriages after god
has blessed our marriage on our wedding
night it will be the first time and my
dad
because we were all pretty devout cath
like he was just like yeah yeah that's
cool that's cool but
if you were ever yeah so suddenly i was
like
wait should i have been doing this the
whole time are all these
glory stories i'm hearing actually
truthful and then we watched uh
as a family we watched the 40 year old
virgin
and we were in the movie theater
watching it and it's the opening part
where steve carell
has like uh you know horrible morning
wood
is going around his apartment like with
his action figures everywhere
and my mom goes eric that's you oh my
god
oh my god oh [ __ ] and i was like
we're in a movie what
oh my god so i was i spent 17 years of
my life
never losing an uh a night of sleep
worried about
whether i was where i needed to be
suddenly i got peer pressure from my
parents you're like what is
wrong with you do it already yeah
get it out of your system well then that
day my
parents saw me crying and they drove me
over to an area where a bunch of sex
workers were and they waited until i was
finished
until i was a man was made out of me and
i'm forever grateful for that
wonderful what a great story dinner and
a movie yep
at least they took me to a movie first
yeah movie and a dessert i guess
[Music]
truthful happy ending no that part
didn't happen but the 40 old virgin
thing when my mom saying i was steve
girl's character did happen
yeah and that's why i have anxiety and
crippling social depression
a lot a lot i will say for both of my
parents
a lot of like uh revisionist history on
how strict they were about it
once we got older because both of my
sisters had babies
like out of wedlock two partners that
they're with like you know in adult
relationships but it was like
all of those things were horrifying to
me as a kid and like
that might then like you know my mom
will anecdotally tell a story about like
my aunt getting pregnant when she was
like 15 or something like that i'm like
what
what where was all this scandal when i
was
a teenager anyway i uh i did not i
haven't been roasted in the movie
theater like that but i have been
roasted
at like a family party by my parents
like being like well tom because you
can't find a girlfriend or something
like that
yeah anyway we gotta have uh next time
we're on together we'll tell our stories
about the worst roasts our families
because i had worse once than that even
oh yeah me too well you'll have to keep
watching big question because that is
our show for this week
reminder to join our official discord
baby community patron at patreon.com
new rockstar so you can also get an
audio version of the show by subscribing
to new rocks there's big questions
wherever you get your podcast
thanks to everyone who submitted
questions and send us your big questions
on twitter using the hashtag bigquestion
follow me at eavos follow tommy at tommy
bechdel thanks so much for joining me
this week tommy
i felt safe talking about this stuff
with you i think we're ready
we're ready to end this show and take
the next step
and don't forget you can always wait
until you're dead
and then you'll die a virgin and go
straight to heaven
this is a daddy
uh no broadway production of hair will
ever be done again in these conditions
follow new rockstars on all of our
social media subscribe here on youtube
to get too much information all those
stuff we care about
see you next week the moon
is in the southern house
[Music]
you